well i'm joined now by brendan cox who
is married to the late joe cox
sister of the newly elected kim
ledbetter
hello to you brendan what does this
result
mean to you as a family
i think we're just very proud of of kim
and the bravery that she's shown in
putting herself forward um i think it is
a very brave thing for people to do in
any uh
circumstance particularly at the moment
given the sort of fraughtness of
of politics but for kim to to put
herself forward in
a in the context where
we lost joe i think takes even more
bravery so for us
as a as a family win or lose uh we were
just incredibly proud that she went into
it both
with that bravery but also with that
positive vision she was relentlessly
positive
about how you bring your community
together and i think that's the thing
that ultimately made the difference for
her
i wonder what you think joe would have
made seeing her sister
now representing the constituency of
batley and spen
i think she'd be very proud of her i
think she'd um
not be surprised at her talent and
ability joe and kim are very different
people
but they certainly share that sense of
how important it is to build
local communities to bring people
together at that at that local level to
build that
inclusive and positive uh vision of of
community and so i think joe would
yeah be um be excited uh would be
bouncing around
um full of optimism about what uh what
kim can
achieve in the house of commons as well
but i think the first thing for
kim and she's talked about will be
concentrating on the community in batley
and spend and helping it heal from what
has been a pretty
divisive campaign where people have
tried to exploit differences i think
the priority for now will be mending
some of those community relations
yeah and you praise kim for her bravery
standing
in the battle and spam by-election it
has been a pretty bruising
period for all involved and at times a
toxic campaign
at kim in her acceptance speech having
to thank the police who she
said she certainly needed over the past
few weeks
yeah i think you know you want
by-election campaigns to be hard-fought
you want the debate to be rigorous you
want it to be passionate
um and as part of that there will
sometimes be um
frayed uh tempers and irritations
but i do think there were there were
some people that stood in this
election who were trying to um
whose priority wasn't even really to win
it but it was to try and divide into
damage um the community and i think
what was clear out of the result while
it was very close between uh the labour
party and the conservative party
what was clear is that the people of
batli and spain had no time
for that division the far-right parties
got less than
0.5 percent of the vote combined they
all lost their deposits
so that's one of the most heartening
things i'll take out of this that yes
people turned up and they tried
to put petrol on the flames of those
community divisions
but ultimately the people in batley and
spen
um answered that with a resounding no
and voted for
candidates that did want to bring
communities together george galloway
though ended up taking votes from both
labour and
the tories coming in third place and
joe sees her majority at 323
what do you think the challenges are now
for her ahead both in healing the
divides in the community
and building that majority
i think the easy thing to do um in
communities
specifically when the community's got um
large differences within them whether
that's on the basis of racial religion
it's very easy to come in and stoke
those differences what is hard and what
politics at its best is about
is understanding those divisions and
those differences but trying to forge
a collective vision and a collective
project for those
for those communities so it's it's the
easiest thing in politics to do which is
to
fan the flames of hate and galloway and
some of the others on the far right
are very practiced and very adept at
doing that however as i said
it didn't work ultimately um the two
main parties got the vast majority of
the boats the vote between them
and i think what kim will be focusing on
now is she's been talking about
are those local issues that actually do
bring people together and whether that
is around
education or the local environment or
potholes
that saying that kim um sorry that joe
uh talked about that we have more in
common than the things that divide us
i think it absolutely comes through when
you start talking about the issues
and stop trying to to fan the flames of
of hatred and division
okay uh brendan cox good to hear from
you thank you